c'était il ya deux ans l'oeil de cesser
alias note il prenait forme sur un
bunker à siouville avec caché dans sa
pupille le reflet de la centrale
nucléaire toute proche
cette oeuvre l'artiste l'avait aussi
voulu éphémère l'oeil s'est donc
refermée il y à peu c'est un enfant qui
couchent etc etc et enfin qui souffrent
kemal
cette fois c'est l'exploitation et la
maltraitance animale quenottes il a
voulu mettre en avant en détournant un
vestige de la seconde guerre
ça vous choque pas non non on les remet
en valeur le pèlerinage à l'éléphant et
son must le selphy envahissent les
réseaux sociaux paris et effet de
surprise réussi pour l'artiste de signes
exprès jallow et alors je trouve ça très
beau très représentatif maintenant on va
attendre la suite pour voir comment il
va exprimer son art autrement qu'elle
suit mystère dans son musée à ciel
ouvert nautile impose son rythme et
reste discret un luxe que le talent lui
permet